but you're not a huge car guy joe huh no
no
no i have a lot you have dope rides but
you're not yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i do i i i buy i buy
nice cars yeah but i don't care do you
have a favorite i don't show them all my
like you have a brand you [ __ ] with i
just bought a porsche
which one the new the 2020 uh 911
uh turbo yeah yeah all right what is
that is that like yours
uh uh it kind of kind of just
we'll be right back we'll be right back
after these nights god damn
i don't know carlos yeah you're gonna
see a bunch of turbos that agents drive
you know yeah oh it's an agent
has the camera turned around yet man
you know they're on my side right every
now and then they're on my side
no but bring up the turbo that that car
is ridiculous
what colors did you get i i matted it
out
what color matte matte black all right
oh yes sir that's what black rims do
uh everything black yeah yeah they're so
fast yeah it's beautiful they're so
it's so fast they're so [ __ ] fast is
it the turbo s
yeah so it's all wheel drive so yeah
yeah it would
yeah it would you know to be honest beat
my car to be honest brandon can i be
honest with you yeah go ahead
i don't know you just like the car no i
i don't know the numbers or anything oh
i do
i think it's a 911 s yeah 911
it's turbo yeah i i but i don't know i'm
just gonna be honest with you you just i
just
yeah i just i like i'm not a car guy i
buy nice cars but i don't know anything
about them i really don't got it that's
cool but
but with the 911 turbo s it's like that
car is
a [ __ ] like off the lot it's up
d
it's beautiful it's so fast and you have
other cars but there's something
different when you drive a porsche
yeah it's my favorite car by far by far
they just it's
it's just looking at it i just want to
get in i just want to get in it
mm-hmm maybe something about it man my
son loves it
no he's not allowed i bought him a poor
she crashed it what which one yeah i
bought him
a con oh that's what cat drives yeah
that's what i have
yeah man your bum how are you crashing
my car he crashed it
yeah he's done you take his hand
would you what'd you get him i i was mad
i was on stage i got off stage my sister
you know walked up to me and she's like
please uh
just be happy he's okay whenever someone
starts [ __ ] off like that
yeah and then she was like your
sunglasses oh my god
in vegas no he did it in uh in l.a damn
so was it bad yeah well yeah it's
totaled it was this recent
yeah it was about two years ago he
totaled it not that recent
yeah he's okay though oh he's okay
that's the big thing
he doesn't want to drive anymore oh he
doesn't yes yeah i think he wants to
wait
yeah i think he's a little traumatized
by it well kids these days don't even
need to get their [ __ ]
you have to be honest with the car yeah
he really did
everywhere yeah he was ubering all the
time he was doing a doordash
you know what i mean like he was doing
that stuff when i was on the road so i
don't know
he's doing door dashing his horse yeah
no no no he was door down
there yeah that's why you're not in
front of the camera
now now i'm a big fan of your merch uh
brandon oh wait wait can i tell you i
did get another car
just recently i got that gladiator brand
new right
jeep gladiator i love it i got it i got
a truck i got it fully loaded it's the
only one with a hemi in it right
what yeah it's got a hemi a v8 it's
really massive
it's everything it's it's lifted what
color uh no
i got uh i got that tan one right there
right there that's that's exactly what i
got but all tan like even the interior's
tan
man that's almost like my car it's
probably uh
and that uh you love it no
uh i'm pissed man i bring it in again
bro bro it's been in the shop
four [ __ ] times i just bought it two
months ago that's a bummer
so what i hate to say this thing is so
nice to me you guys over at jeep i love
you they've been so nice they're
probably gonna see this
but still yeah but i'm so frustrated
and i haven't said anything for you know
literally the week i got it had to bring
it in because oil leaked yeah
and then i i drove on to set you know i
was
at this netflix show get it off your
chest and
explosion what oil all over their lot
man
first brand new they had to tow it on a
flat bed
i got on video that's embarrassing and
then i called them they
and look man they're all doing their job
to make it work yeah
but now and then i i got it back again
oil leaked again you got a lemon
no because it's not three of the same
thing it's always different things but
i'm just saying
it's like there's always silo so then
they they had it for almost two weeks to
give it back everything they
did everything man they detailed it they
painted my dash they made it all oh they
changed my wheels
you know i mean they gave me like better
wheels yeah and then uh
end tires wheels and tires they gave me
the whole set just to make up for what
what happened
and then uh the horn wasn't working
start
in the horn i'm like what the [ __ ] the
horns that were just had to bring it
back again stop it you need your horn
bro whose horn doesn't work
exactly so i get the horn back
right and now i'm driving like yesterday
and it's clanking behind the brakes
every time i step on the brakes it's
going to clip
clunk clunk so i called him i
literally i just texted him uh yesterday
and he didn't keep that i told him i go
dude i i think this is a lemon
yes yeah yeah i i can't keep doing this
i can't
yeah talk to him paid for this car it's
like
i paid a hundred and twenty for this
yeah for a cheap
bro oh jeep jeeps are disposable cars
thank you [ __ ] i'm sorry i'm sorry
it is frustrating i was i was frustrated
parking because it kept making it sound
oh you did you drove it here yeah i
drove it so it was clunking like you
know when you step on the right it's
like clunk
can i drive no it just makes you mad
yeah you can have it
you need it i don't have a car no he
wants a jeep
this is a make a wish foundation right
here joe yeah we're on your side right
now baby may give him a wish yeah we're
gonna get you a car
we're gonna get you we're one two listen
to these
people without cars always have nice
shoes that is true
it's usually bad decisions okay first of
all
but you can't move around i bullied you
into these
you you picked those yeah you did pick
those where'd you go to get those
he wanted the same plug that i have i
love it
who's your plug i don't have a plug oh
they just
you don't need one no okay i just get it
look look i just get it
from my watch
how's your watching with melanie
you show me those off-white ones i
showed you all five oh that was
so funny those jordans i'm like look
what i just got he goes
cool man i've had them for two years
that's one
i think i had them longer yeah i had
them like three or four years those are
the
minute they came out i got them the
minute they came out i got it they're so
dope with the green laces yeah they got
to be the one the best shoes ever yeah
yeah that's right i'm obsessed with them
yeah obsessed they're so sick so back to
this jeep yeah yeah
uh i hate it what are we gonna say about
i've had that same problem though
because
i bought mine's a little different
because i bought a raptor and then i
had him hook it up and when you hook it
up the warranty
ford doesn't cover the warranty yeah so
i it came hooked up like
bigger turbos chipped everything so it
was this monster 600 horsepower
always had issues if i floored it on the
highway it would just shut down
so i couldn't i still get on the highway
it'd be you had to go like 20
30. oh you had to gradually someone in a
race dude
it was so dangerous it was so dangerous
not the quarter mile
the two mile let's go
we're like 100
if you put too much gas into it shut
down because these big turbos
and then uh i went to pull up at the
economy store
and the lot guy's like dude we can't
like what the [ __ ] are we gonna do with
this it's too big we can't park it here
yeah so i was like i can't park here
like no so i every time i drive i have
to park down the street or park in
the [ __ ] way up in the hills like
[ __ ] this thing man
it kept kept on [ __ ] up like yours
and then ford's like you're the one that
[ __ ] with it i'm like
the guy [ __ ] with it i didn't [ __ ]
with her like we don't care so
i got rid of it oh damn that's the worst
here's the thing
they sold me this car yeah i didn't add
it you should be under warranty yeah
yeah man
i so i gotta go back to vegas and i'm
just going to just drive it in and be
like just give me another car
yeah i have to right hot dude 110
percent
annoying ridiculous and usually i was so
mad walking in here
oh there's nothing worse we have car
problems especially when you pay for it
like
you took a
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figured out what you look like i'm
like what just run a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son